Good afternoon. Well, I am
so delighted to be here.
Google is really one of my favorite
places to work and to talk.
So when I want to talk about today is
I want to talk about what I call the
contribution gap and our personal brands.
So a few years ago I had a six month
period and in that six month period I left
a long marriage after a couple
of decades and got a divorce.
My step all within six months,
my stepfather dropped dead.
My stepfather died of a lung disease.
My father dropped dead after,
after a heart attack,
two weeks later I moved from California
to New York and then back to California
again.
And as one of my friends said,
you know how there's those scales of
things you're not supposed to do because
they can kill you. There's things
like move or a death in the family.
They increase your rate of death. She
said, you're not supposed to do even one,
one of them, let alone all six of
them in a short period of time.
And so it really made me stop and I had
to stop and I had to step back and I had
to take a look at what did I want
the next period of my life to be,
what really was my contribution
in the next period of my life?
And so I went on this long year long
research project about what is really at
the heart of our contribution,
what is really at the heart
of our personal brands.
And what I want to share with you
today is what I found out in that year.
Because what I found out in that year
really changed my own personal brand.
It changed how I think about things.
It changed how I work.
It changed how I work with clients. And
I found that in that research that I did,
there's a lot we can learn about our
brands and our contribution that isn't
always the way that we talk about them.
And I'm so that's what I want
to talk about with you today.
I want to share what I learned
in that research with you today.
The first thing I want to ask you to do,
I know everyone sat down,
but the first thing I'd love
to ask everybody to do is
just to stand up for one
minute and I just sat down,
but stand up for one minute and what I'd
like you to do is say hello to one or
two people around you only.
Here's the catch. Say Hello.
Like you're really looking for someone
a lot more important to say hello to.
All right, so if everybody
would just do that for a minute,
go ahead and say hello.
All right.
Now would you please say hello to
somebody next to you or around you,
but say hello.
Like they're your long lost friend and
you're thrilled to have found them again.
All right, stop. Very good.
Thank you. And have a seat.
So you know how in that first one
it was a little bit like miss. So,
so in the second one, the the volume,
I saw many more hugs in the second one,
right?
And the volume goes up.
I think when we have a really strong
idea of our personal brand and we have a
really strong idea of what we contribute,
it's much easier to
connect with other people.
It's almost like we walk into the room
with that because sense of connection is
much more palatable and it isn't
that it's bad. The first experience,
it's just a little sort of empty. And
what I call that as the contribution gap,
when we're really clear about our brand,
when we're really clear about our
contribution than what we have,
is this a way to instantly
almost connect with other people?
Whether these are people at a conference,
whether there are people we work with,
whether they're people
in a social situation,
it gives us that sense of what our
contribution is. We walk in with that.
And so what I studied in that year that
I had was what the contribution gap was
in my own life and what the contribution
contribution gap was in other people's
lives.
And one of the things I found in my
research is one of the things that gets in
the way of our brands being the
strongest and our contribution making our
greatest contribution is what
I call the myth of roles.
And this is all the I am's in our
life. I am a mother, I am a wife,
I am a software engineer,
I am a dancer, right?
I am a cat lover, I am a dog lover.
I'm a fan of game of Thrones.
Whatever your I am's are,
whatever your roles are.
And so I discovered that these roles
really are one of the things that get in
the way of our contribution.
And for some of you,
like what are some of the roles that
you have? You can just shout it out.
Some of the roles that you have, personal
or professional daughter. Exactly.
What else? Husband. Yes. What else?
Roommate. Exactly. Googler.
Yes. Very important role.
But what's the problem with all roles?
Eventually what happens to all roles?
Eventually they end,
right? They, by their nature,
all roles eventually end.
And so if we think our contribution or
the heart of our contribution is about
our roles, then what happens is when
they end, we find ourselves going, well,
who am I?
What is it that I have to contribute?
That's a lot of what happened when my
father died and I stopped being someone's
my father's daughter.
It was still my mother's daughter.
But when I stopped being
my father's daughter when I
got a divorce and I was now
not someone's wife,
and you know,
all of these roles and I wasn't
to California in anymore.
And so all these roles started to
change and I started to say, well,
if I'm not all of that, who I am, I,
so one of the things that gets in the
way of our personal brands and our
contributions is this myth of
the roles who we think we are.
The other thing I discovered in
my research in a, by the way I,
I interviewed several thousand people
all over the world in different companies
and male, female does,
despite age, race, gender,
it didn't matter. What I found was
there was a lot of commonalities.
And the other commonality was this
myth of knowledge and results.
A lot of us define our brands and our
contribution by the results we produce or
what we know. The writer Gretchen cryer
calls that the, I know the world's up.
So what are the worlds that we know,
right?
Like you might know the worlds of
volleyball or the world of travel,
or the world of Google or the world of
speaking French or the world of dogs.
There's million that you can know
and all that is part of our brand.
But that's not the heart of our
contribution or the heart of our brand.
And so the other thing I've found in my
research is that people often get very
stifled because they think that
their brand or they think that their,
their contribution are
these worlds that they know.
So if it's not those two
things, what is it? Well,
here's what I found in my research.
I found that our brands
and our contribution at the
heart of them is what I call
the, whether you bring with you, it's
the thing when you walk into the room,
it just comes with you.
It's the thing that people feel from us.
It's the thing that people can sense
about us and feel from us the moment they
walk into a room without
knowing anything about us.
So I'll give you an example of this.
I was walking in the lower east side of
Manhattan about a year ago with a friend
and we see this woman,
a traffic cop and she's directing traffic
and she hasn't just directing traffic.
She's doing it like it's ballet.
Now I have the greatest respect
for New York city traffic cops.
That is a hard job.
But a lot of them often look,
have the look on their face like this
would be a great job if it wasn't for all
those people driving cars and this woman
is leaping and she's jumping and she's
going, come on sir, go this
way ladies cross the street.
She is so alive and so
enthusiastic and we're all just,
all the pedestrians are standing
there like this. Wow. Like,
we're just watching this and the cars
are honking at her and waving and she is
this great example of bringing the,
whether you bring with you,
she has just got this a lightness in
this joy and she's making this amazing
contribution.
And of course she's completely
establishing her brand by
what she's doing right.
But she's doing it in this
really enthusiastic, excited
way and cars are honking.
And the thing that was amazing about this
woman was did she know she had a solid
role as like a traffic cop? Yes. I'm sure
she did. What she knowledgeable, yes.
I'm sure she was knowledgeable
in all thing traffic laws,
but it wasn't her role or her
knowledge that was making a difference.
It was the way she was doing it.
It was the weather that she was bringing
with her that was making a difference.
And in the work that I did,
and in the research that I did,
I actually found that there's
some archetypes or there
are some ways that people
typically contribute and I call these
brand energies or brand archetypes.
These are,
and there were 12 of them.
I actually could identify and find 12
core brand archetypes of how we approach
our personal brands and how we contribute.
And the interesting thing about these
brand energies is all of us have access to
all these energies, right? Any of us
can step into any of these at any time.
But usually there's one or two that
when we look back to being kids,
we can see that way, way,
way back, we had this,
this is something that we,
we had even as kids,
this is always in a way Brent
been what we bring to the party.
It's been the weather
that we bring with us.
And so I want you to go through
these 12 archetypes with you.
Cause I want you to think about as I go
through them, where do you see yourself?
But where do you see the
people that you work with?
Because one of the other things I found
in a row in the research was that the
best marriages, the best
teams, the best departments,
the best problem solving groups,
all of those people had people
with different contribution styles,
with different brand energies that it
wasn't just one that when you had people
with a mix, when you had more of
a diversity of contribution style,
things went a lot better because people
brought different things to the party.
So I'm going to go through the 12
that I discovered with you now for the
overachievers in here who were like, no,
I'm not just one or two, I'm all 12 fine,
you can be all 12 but generally you'll
notice as I go through that you usually
tend to be leaning more in the
direction of one or the other.
And that's important.
It's important to know which ones you
are because then you can invite other
people to the party and to be on teams
with you and to work with you who are
different, who actually bring a different
kind of energy and contribution.
And when you're putting teams together,
you can consciously think about how am
I going to have this team reflect all of
those different kinds of energies or at
least a mix. So it's not just one type.
So here was one of them. These are people
whose, whether they bring with them,
their contribution is the fixer and the
fixer is the person that's the healer
there restore their,
the mender.
These are the people that you give when
a problem needs to be solved because you
know that that's the thing that they love.
My friend Joanna used to talk about her
dad who was in real estate and she'd say
her father would come into work every
morning. He'd sit down as a desk,
he'd roll up his sleeves, he get his cup
of coffee out, and he literally say, okay,
what problems do we have today?
And he was excited.
He was excited to see what problems,
uh, showed up. Not to know about you,
but I do not go into my office
every morning and go, wow,
what problems do we have today at tends
not to be my relationship with problems.
I have other things I do, but not
that. So fixers love problems.
That's one of the things
that's in that archetype there.
Really those kinds of people,
useful people to have on a team,
useful energy to have because those
people are able to literally take that
attitude towards making
something better and solve it.
Then you have people that are facilitators
and this archetype is people that are
mediators and moderators and go between.
So you know,
these are the people that are able to
take all these different groups and
different people and get them aligned
and going in the same direction.
Amazing skill to have, right?
Amazing contribution to make.
Then you have people that
are storytellers, right?
And storytellers are these
narrators and orders and minstrels.
These are the people,
whether it's through writing or whether
it's through painting or whether it's
through video or whether it's through
dance or whether it's through theater.
These are the people that are able to
convey this emotion and this feeling
through story and those are incredibly
important people to have in our world and
in our life and our teams.
Because when you have that brand of
being a storyteller, when that's the,
whether you bring with you,
you're able to translate all of these
things in a way that's very powerful.
You know,
one of the things that I learned in my
research was that metaphor and stories
was one of the best way to get your point
across to somebody that when you could
speak in metaphors and stories,
people were able to hear it in a much
different way than when it was just pure
straight facts and figures.
Then you have people that are
synthesizers and people who the,
whether they bring with
them as synthesizers and the
energy that they bring with
them. These are the integrators and the
blenders and the producers. You know,
these are the people that are able
to take all these disparate things,
put them together and
create something new.
And those synthesizers are people that
we rely on because they're able to see
something new in all of
the different elements.
And there it's a really wonderful rich
archetype and a really wonderful enrich
brand energy because bringing all those
things together is often the thing that
transforms it.
You know,
from a caterpillar to a butterfly
transforms it into something brand new and
beautiful.
Then you have people that are mentors
and the mentors are interesting because
these are the people
whose contribution there.
They're real essence of their brand is
being advisors and teachers and guides.
And I love this picture.
This is actually a photo that I took at
the think it's the wizarding world of
Harry Potter.
I was visiting with some friends in
their kids and this little kid saw one of
these minions and the look on
this child's face was like,
he had just seen God, ah, and he
wandered the parents there. You know,
when the kid wanders up to the minion
and you can see the way he's just kissing
the minion and looking at them.
But often our relationship with mentors
is we look up to them and we admire them
so much because it's the
people with this energy.
They're the people that are
really shepherding us along
and helping us make our
goals and helping us be the
best people that we can be.
And so this mentor energy is incredibly
important and valuable as a contribution.
That's the thing about all
these archetypes. One isn't
better than the other.
One is not more useful than the other
one isn't more desirable than the other.
They're all useful and that's why when
you have teams or groups or people that
have a mix of them together,
you get tend to get a better result
because you're getting all of these
different energies together. You're
getting all of these different archetypes,
which you can see you really
need to produce the best outcome.
And really owning the archetype that we
are really owning what our contribution
is and being certain about
our contribution and really
making it is a big part
of people who have strong personal brands.
They know to the depth of their being
what that contribution is and they trust
it.
They trust their own contribution.
That is what I found in my research was
these people were very solid in what
their contribution was. It doesn't mean
they couldn't step into other energies,
but they really saw the
depth of that contribution.
Then you have people that are connectors.
These are some of my
favorite kinds of energies.
There's people that are connectors and
these are the networkers in the arrangers
and the coordinators.
These are the people that you'll
go to a party and they'll go, hey,
you should know such and such and I'm
going to do an email and introduce you to
this person because you two should
talk to each other about this,
that and the other thing. They're
always putting people together, right?
And the people they put together magically
seem to be perfect for each other in
terms of the contribution
they can make to each other.
Then you have people that are
visionaries and the visionaries are the
conceptualizers and the
idealist and the dreamers,
and these are the people that
are able to see something.
And actually come up with the
concept of what it should be, right?
These are the people that are
actually able to stop and go,
foom we're doing it this way, but maybe
we could do it that way. You know,
this is sort of this ideal that I have.
Then we have people that are motivators
and motivators are a little bit
different than mentors.
They might mentor,
but motivators of those people that
can light a fire under us right there.
The cheerleaders and the
influencers and the persuaders,
these are the people that really can get
a group of people going on a team and a
group individually with friends.
These are the people that they just walk
in the door and what they bring with
them is this instant sort of cheeriness
and influence and ability to persuade.
Then you have the people that are the
makers and these are the artisans and the
creators and the inventors
and these people could be
creating code or they could
be creating paintings. I have this thing
I talk about is the everyday artist.
One of the things I discovered in my
research was everyone is what I call an
everyday artist. Every single person
has something about what they do.
That's art.
Doesn't matter if their computer coding.
It doesn't matter if they're a doctor,
it doesn't matter if they're a painter.
Everyone has something that they
do that a part of it is their art.
It's the way they do it,
where they're creating,
and these people literally are driven
by inventing and creating an art.
That's their whole world. It's not just
painting. It's not just being on stage.
It could be, I've known people that
are artisans that that's their makers,
that's their essential self.
They're essential contribution and what
they're making is code or what they're
making our products, but it's that,
that feeling of that they're creating.
Then you have people that are advocates
and these are the people that are the
activists and the champions
and the campaigners.
These are the people that you invite
to a dinner party and they can't help,
but they're going to talk about what
they're passionate about and what they're
advocating for no matter what.
Even at a dinner party.
That's their energy that
they bring with them.
Then you have people that are
implementers and these are achievers and
administrators and executors.
These people are awesome because
it's one thing to have ideas.
It's another thing,
right?
To have those ideas actually get
implemented and so these people are really
amazing at taking something from a
concept and an idea and making it happen.
Then you have people that are interpreters
and these are the people that are
able to translate and change and
transform an idea or a group of ideas and
interpreted in a way that's something
completely new happens that comes in
completely new occurs because they're
able to take all those different parts and
not only synthesize them but interpret
them in a totally new and different way.
So what gets in the way of those things,
right? Those are, those are some of our,
our contributions and archetypes.
What gets in the way of them? Well,
the first thing is is do
you know what yours is?
Can you have a sense of
what your archetype is?
Actually what I'd love everybody to do
is just kind of quickly pair up with
someone next to you and have those
ones that I just ran through.
Which one do you,
which one or two do you think you are?
Which one resonates
most strongly with you?
And then which one or two
reminded you of someone you know,
so everybody just get a partner and
really quickly just sort of with your
partner share with that is
great.
So let me just hear some
examples of what you,
which one resonated with you personally?
Which ones resonated with you personally?
Let me just hear some examples.
Visionary.
Visionary. Okay, great. Who else?
That's an implementer
and implementer.
Okay.
So you know what's interesting
is if we put these two together,
there are a perfect pair,
right?
Cause we have the vision and
then we have implementation.
What happens when you have a team? Just
evolve. Visionaries, they're happy,
they're excited, but nothing gets
done because they're not implementers.
What happens when you have
a team of all implementers?
Okay.
They can, yeah, they're
awesome at getting it done,
but they could be going in the wrong
direction or they could be going into
limited direction, which is why we need
everyone's contribution. Whites is widest.
Diversity of contribution is
really, really important. Why?
It's important to have this inclusion
of different people who have different
contributions to bring in teams
and groups, et Cetera. Who else?
Did we just hear a few
other examples over here?
Yeah,
there's connectors. Yes.
You're all like together.
The connectors are all connected. Okay,
perfect. You manage to find each other.
Great. So how many of you could see your
coworkers in this? Just raise your hands.
Yep.
Your bosses,
your wives maybe see their animals ruins.
While people say to me,
I think my dogs that connect or I'm like,
okay,
so what gets in the way of this?
Well,
one of the things I found in the research
was that one of the big things that
gets in the way that creates
a contribution gap is
our fear of missing out.
You know?
And we live in a world where it's easier
than ever to have this fear of missing
out, isn't it? Because every
time we turn on, you know,
the iPhone or the thing or the
Google, whatever, we're using,
whatever PDA we're using, the
Google, the iPhone, whatever.
Every time we turn it on, what happens?
We look at Facebook and we see,
oh, that person's living so
much of a better life than I am.
They're having so much more fun than I am.
It doesn't.
Everyone's life looks so much better
than ours. Come on, tell the truth.
Do you know? It's like I'm always
looking and going, well, wow,
Kim Carr Dashi and didn't retweet my
picture of my macaroni and cheese.
How come I want to be the
mother of dragons? You know?
So what happens is we have this fear
of missing out that happens in part,
we have, social media has been wonderful
for a lot of things and I love it,
but it's also contributed
to this fear of missing out.
It's contributed to this idea that somehow
everybody's living this better life
than we are.
And the fear of missing out was one of
the things that my research showed really
got in the way of people's contribution.
And it also created a sense of isolation.
It created a sense of,
I'm sort of here in my
world doing my thing,
and other people are in their world
doing their thing and we're not really
always connected. Even though
we might be connected on social,
we're not always connecting.
So what I found in the research was that
this fear of missing out led to a sense
of emptiness that had people not
really believe or have faith in their
contribution,
like their contribution wasn't enough,
their contribution was
somehow insufficient or not
enough to bring to the party.
That's one of the things that gets in
the way. So how do you bridge that gap?
Well, I think you bridge that
gap a couple of the ways.
And one of the ways you bridge it is by
practicing what my friend Lynette calls
the joy of missing out.
So instead of the fear of missing out,
you practice the joy of missing out.
I love Lynette because I will say to her,
Lynette, do you want to go to the
movie? And she'll go, yeah, no,
I don't really feel like doing that.
And I'll go, okay, well Lynette,
do you want to do this? No,
I don't think so. Does that.
Then Lynnette doesn't participate.
She just isn't afraid of
missing out on things.
So she really has that
joy of not doing things.
And how many times do we do something
because we have a fear of missing out on
it. We're just afraid to say no cause we
might miss this opportunity or we might
miss this person or something might
happen. You know, a few years ago,
I love to travel. Travel is one of my
most favorite things in the world to do.
And a few years ago I got
invited to go with a girlfriend.
A friend of mine was going
to go to Iceland and she
had a small group of people
put together some friends.
So I decided to go to Iceland.
I'd never been there to see the northern
lights. Now, I know that Iceland is cold,
but I thought Iceland was
cold the Way New York is cold.
And what I found out is no, Iceland
is not cold the Way New York is cold,
it's much,
much colder.
So I as a result was not properly
dressed in Iceland and it was,
I think it was in the winter of two.
So I was not properly dressed
in Iceland and I looked good,
but I was really cold and I was so cold
that I actually got violently sick,
like seriously sick and Iceland.
And so I spent most of my time
in bed with a cold recovering.
It was just one of those trips that
didn't, nothing turned out right.
Rarely happens what I traveled,
but nothing turned out.
And so I got home from Iceland
and I was like, okay, that's it.
And Lynette and I have a good friend
named Theresa and Theresa to me.
Maybe a week after I got
back from Iceland. Karen,
a bunch of us are going to go, uh, on a,
on a trip. Do you want to come with us?
And I was like, hell no. And
I think I said something else,
but I said, hell no, I do not want to go
on that trip. And they were like, oh no,
it'll really be fun. It's gonna be an
interesting thing. But I was like, no,
I don't want to go on.
The trip was overseas somewhere and then
about three months or four months goes
by and Theresa is talking to me about
their trip and I go and I literally say to
her, what do you mean you
guys are going on the trip?
How come you didn't invite me? And she
goes to, we did it by you. You said,
hell no. And I said, Oh, I must've been
in my post Iceland. She goes, yeah,
you were in your post Iceland phase.
You were not feeling like
going on that trip. So anyway,
they all went on the trip and they were
sending me pictures from the bus and
they're all having a good time.
And I started feeling like that fear of
missing out, like darn it, I missed out.
I missed out on going on that trip.
And then all of a sudden I realized,
you know what?
I didn't go on that trip,
but the country they went to isn't going
anywhere. I didn't go on that trip.
But you know what? Look at all
these other things I got to do.
Cause I didn't go on that trip.
And I started to see
how even in retrospect,
we look at things and we have this fear
of missing out about things that have
already passed.
Does everyone know what I'm talking about?
And then we spend our mind like,
oh,
I should have gone to that meeting where
I should've been at that party or I
should have done this thing. And so the,
this fear of missing out, the alternative,
the key to really giving our contribution
is to step into the joy of missing out.
It's like really practicing that.
If something isn't the right
thing for us at the time,
we're going to have the
joy of missing out in it.
We're going to have the joy of saying
no to the things that aren't right.
And that saying yes to
the things that are right.
So I have a contribution challenge
for you, and here's the challenge.
It's really in the next month only
do things that are really within your
greatest contribution.
Only do things that are really on the
path of your greatest contribution.
Only say yes to those things that really
feel like they're within your gift.
The gift that you have to give.
No.
Obviously there's things your boss is
going to ask you to do that you can't say,
Oh, I'm sorry that's not within my gift
or my contribution. I won't be doing that.
Yeah, don't do that. But you know,
there's other things that you're going
to want to say yes to that really aren't.
They're out of a fear of missing out.
Just say no to those things because
saying notice those things has a certain
power to it.
That makes a huge difference when you
start moving in that direction. So that's,
it's one of the things I found is
when people took on this contribution
challenge, it made a huge
difference. The other thing is that,
take a look at how you're represented
in terms of your brand in the world.
So what does that mean? Number one
in business, that means linkedin.
Take a look at your linkedin profile
and see it doesn't really represent me.
I get calls everyday from people that
asked me to work with them on their
personal brand. First thing I do is
check out their linkedin profiles.
And as many of you,
your linkedin profile is a lot of people
like up to 77% of the people that are
going to talk to or work with you.
We're going to check you
out on linkedin first.
So having your linkedin profile really
reflect and represent you is one of the
key things to having your brand
in the world be solidified.
You know,
I always tell people they should be
googling themselves at least once a month.
You'd just put your name in on Google
and Google yourself once a month and see
what comes up. You know, how are
you being represented in the world?
So your, your linkedin is one of
the places you want to think about.
How are you representing your brand?
Are you just giving a recitation of your,
everything you've done of your resume or
are you actually having a little bit of
there in the summary of who you
are and what you contribute?
I don't mean writing
the archetypes in there.
I mean talking a little bit
about what you're committed to,
talking a little bit about what it
is you bring to the party. You know,
always tell people there's summaries.
Ought to have a little bit of that feeling
of what's the weather you bring with
you when that's in your summary and
your Google, I mean in your linkedin,
excuse me. Then it makes a big difference.
People can get a sense of that.
So one is,
are you represented on your linkedin in
a way where your brand really shows up?
Because in the world we live in today,
that's one of the places people go.
I don't know if you all have seen
this yet, but you know now on your,
on my calendar, on my, on my cell,
when I go to meet with somebody
I haven't met with before,
a little message will pop up that says
you're going to meet with such and such
soon, would you like to
see their linkedin profile?
So it's automatically taking me to
see people's linkedin profile when I'm
meeting with someone I haven't
met with before the or they don't,
it doesn't recognize this someone I know.
So that's going to be just standard and
I think in about a year that's going to
just be built into every
calendar program everywhere,
regardless of what you're using.
So that kind of access to people is,
is part of how our brands are getting
defined. So how do you show up online?
What's your linkedin look like?
That's the reason LinkedIn's important
is because it's the business to business
one.
It's the biggest business to business one.
But then how are you
represented on Facebook? Listen,
I know people who have stuff on Facebook,
pictures,
shots of taking Tequila shots as they get
out of the ocean, half dressed, right?
Really saying really inflammatory things
politically on both sides of the aisle
doesn't matter,
right?
I have people that have have stuff
on their Facebook that I'm saying,
do you want an employer
to really see that?
Do you want a potential client you're
meeting with to really see that?
Because that shaping their narrative
about you and they can find it.
So part of it is thinking about how
also do we represent ourselves online.
You know,
I think we've gotten really loose about
just putting anything online we want on
Facebook or Twitter. And while
there's a certain freedom to that,
a freedom of expression,
there's also a certain consequence in
terms of how it shapes our brand in the
world.
So it's thinking about the social media
and how are you represented in social
media. And then the other
thing is thinking about what,
what I call these are brand projects. What
projects do you take on at work, right?
What projects do you say yes to
that can help shape your brand?
And what projects do you say no to?
Because they're really not on your path?
Oftentimes we don't look for those
brand projects and we need to,
we need to look for projects at work
that help us shape that brand. You know?
And then there's other ways
to start to build your brand,
whether it's a podcast or
it's blogging or it's writing,
or it's doing articles or
it's speaking on panels.
Everyone today for their own career
has to start to think about what is my
strategy for managing my personal brand?
Obviously you have to take
a few things into account.
One is what are the policies of
your company let you do? You know,
there's some limitations usually
with companies about what we can do.
So given that you're operating within
those policies, what are you going to do?
The other thing is what are your gifts?
If you're a great writer,
then you should probably
to be doing some writing.
You should probably be blogging somewhere
or at least contributing to some
articles. If you're a great
writer, if you're a great speaker,
maybe you should be doing a podcast or
being interviewed on a podcast for your
expertise or your area, right?
If you're really a good speaker,
maybe you should be on a panel
for a conference for your area.
Those are the kinds of things that you
want to start to think about building
because they take your contribution from
being something abstract to something
tangible. And it's one thing for us to
know what our contribution is and feel it.
It's another thing to make it tangible
in our companies and in the world,
and so it's really on us to make sure
we're shaping our brands out in the world
in a way where people can get it. And by
the way, when I say shaping our brands,
I don't mean lying, exaggerating, making
things up. I'm not a fan of any of that.
I'm talking about the authentic expression
of who we are and what's effective
for us,
but to many people I see really don't
take enough effort to shape their brand
when they think they maybe don't need
to because of the level they're at. Two,
they don't think they need to because
they're already gainfully employed and
they're not looking for another job.
But the reality is is those things
do start to shape our brand.
I'll give you one really simple example.
This was years ago,
a friend of mine told me this story.
She used to work in a company with
a woman and the woman was, you know,
like a mid level manager
in a fortune 500 company.
Her name was Susan and Susan would get
in the elevator and oftentimes just
because of the the floor she was
on and the timing of her meetings,
she would often find herself
in the elevator with this,
with the CEO of the company. Say, Susan,
how are you today? I'm fine. How are you?
It's good. How's everything going? It's
good. I was a little rainy today. Oh,
it was snowing today and that was
the degree of their conversation.
And then Susan started working on a
personal brand and she said one day she
realized that how she must seem to
the CEO is like the weather girl.
Cause every time he asked her how she was,
that's what she talked about.
So she started to get in the elevator and
he would say, Susan, how are you today?
And she goes, I'm great. And he'd go,
really? That's good. And she'd go, yeah,
my team and I are working on
a really fabulous project.
And every time she saw the CEO she
would just do a little bit like that.
And within a few months she said she had
been invited to be on a task team that
he was running for a major initiative in
the organization cause she reshaped his
experience of her.
He reshaped his experience of her brand.
So while we're not trying to do anything
again that's exaggerating or lying,
we're trying to be authentic. It's
important to be authentic in our brands.
We have to do it in a way
where other people can get it.
If they can't get it and get the message,
there's no real point to it.
So just remember that it's not enough
for you to know what the weather is you
bring with you. You have to translate it
into ways that the people you work with,
that the people in the outside
world can actually see,
can actually feel that starts to
create that narrative about yourself.
So here's the thing I
want to leave you with.
It's not what you know that's important.
It's knowing what's important.
That's what makes a difference
is knowing what's important.
It's not the script that you follow,
it's really the script that you
write for yourself. And lastly,
it isn't really the,
whether you find,
but the weather you bring with you
that makes the biggest difference.
So thank you very much for your
time and your attention. Thank you.
It's been a pleasure to be here
and I'm going to take some questions.
So please anybody have any questions about
anything about any aspect of personal
branding? I think we have Mike's right
there, right? Is that where the Mikes are?
Okay. Fantastic. Yes, please.
Um, so you talk about like kind of
projecting internally what you bring,
but I was just wondering if you have any
advice around just understanding what
you're projecting to other people.
So I think like we can
know ourselves very well,
but knowing also what other people see
and getting feedback on that to make sure
that we're,
yeah, that's a great question because
here's what happens is it's like you said,
we, we, we think we know
how we're coming across,
but I always say you can't see the
inside of your own eyelids. Right?
It's really hard to tell. So I
think one of the things, there's,
there's a couple of ways to do that.
One is to,
to have people that you trust
and you trust not only their,
the way they look at you and you know,
their ability to see you,
but you trust that there'll be
honest with you and you can ask them,
how do you think I came across and that
meeting? What do you think my brand is?
You know,
one of things I always tell all new
clients to do is I tell them to go talk to
six people they know and say,
if you were to just give me a few
descriptions of what you think my personal
brand are, what are they? And
people often come back and go,
they're shocked at how consistent it is.
That's what people are shocked at is
how does six different people from six
different places know that the shortcut
to this by the way is ask your spouse or
your boyfriend or girlfriend because
they always know. They always know.
So that's one thing is really what is,
you can ask the people that you know,
you can also be more formal and actually
when you get your 360 [inaudible] are,
when you do something like that,
you can ask people to give you their
impression of what your personal brand is
as an additional sort of piece of that.
But it is important to get that feedback.
The thing is you have to establish a
relationship with people where they're
going to be honest about
giving you that feedback.
And that means no consequences.
So you have to say to people,
you can say anything that you really
see and there will be no consequences.
I won't hold it against you.
I bring it up, et cetera.
That's one really good way to do it. Yeah.
Thank you. What else? Other questions?
Yes.
One. Um, what about people
I've seen a lot lately.
People that rebrand their name,
their own name themselves. So we,
I see a lot of executives that all of a
sudden their signatures signed off with
the shorter different name.
I've got friends that are lawyers that
now call themselves slightly different
version of the name. Cause I think like
for example, one light, her name's Kate,
she now calls herself Katie and
everyone has to call herself Katie.
Like what's your take on,
I think like our executive teams seem
to do this branding training and they've
all got different names.
Like what's your take on pit?
Like I've always thought like you
can't choose the keycard people.
It has to be honest.
God gave you that name.
Yeah, stick with it.
It doesn't feel authentic.
So what do you teach that or
like what's your take on that?
No, I'm, what's your name? My
name is Brent. Brent? Yeah.
Cause we could make you the big bay.
Yeah,
no I don't generally teach that people
change their name unless they have a
really a name that's problematic.
So I had a woman who called me in,
her company was named Oak Hitting Isis
and it was a healthcare company and she
called me because she was
very upset cause she says,
I've had this name of my company for
20 years and I don't want to change it.
I'm like, look, I'm sorry, but
there's just no way around this one.
You are going to have to change
the name of your company.
So are there times when you
have to change your name? Yes,
but I'm not in general a fan.
I'm not criticizing anyone.
If that's what they want to do,
that's fine.
I don't think that really
what rebranding is about.
To me that's kind of a
shallow way to rebrand.
I think what real rebranding is
about is when you've discovered,
it's like I used to have a friend that
used to say before you can have a new
reputation, you have to be responsible
for the reputation you have currently.
So to me what real
rebranding is is when you,
you realize you have a certain reputation
and it's not what you want and it's
time to really make some deep changes
in yourself and externally to that.
So I think sometimes people do,
and I don't know any of these people,
so I'm not saying they've done that.
But I think sometimes what people do is
they try to fix their brand with a name
change or a logo change or just changing.
Like I used to wear blue jackets,
now I'm wearing red jackets. Do
you know? And all of that's fine.
But that isn't really
what makes an impact.
That isn't really the depth of branding
that really makes a difference.
So I think the problem is
when we try to rebrand,
rebrand in a shallow way or we try
to rebrand just on the surface,
I guess would be a better way to say it.
When we try to brand on the surface,
it lacks a certain impact than depth.
And you run the risk of
seeming an authentic.
And that's the problem with
that kind of surface rebranding.
Does that make sense? Yeah,
it's a great question. Please.
Hi.
Um,
I'm curious if in your research you found,
um,
a couple insights about vulnerability
because you're calling us to be authentic
to Kinda like put ourselves out
there and be more open to scrutiny.
So I'm kind of wondering how,
if that surfacing your research
and does that play out?
That's first of all,
that's such a great question and that
absolutely surfaced in my research.
So how many people here have seen Bernay
Brown's Tedx talk of the Houston Tedx
talk on the power of vulnerability and,
but he seen that in here. If you haven't,
I want to highly recommend that.
That's a really powerful video,
but similar to what Bernay Brown
is talking about. In that video,
I found that the people that had
the strongest personal brands,
positive personal brands,
let me qualify it like that cause
there can be negative personal brands,
but people that had the strongest
positive personal brands where people that
were seen as being authentic and what
made them authentic was their humility and
their vulnerability. So they were
willing to say, I made that mistake,
I screwed that up.
I'm trying to do this and I failed at it.
I they didn't look like they
were all together. Like, Oh,
I've had it all together and everything's
perfect in my life and you know,
I have 2.7 kids and my marriage is
fabulous and don't I look great.
They didn't have that. They were
really willing to say, I'm struggling.
I'm struggling with my kids.
I'm struggling with my marriage.
I'm struggling in my job. I'm having
a trouble with this particular part.
I don't mean they were dumping it
on people, but they were really,
really willing to be authentic and honest
and vulnerable about their struggles.
How many of you, when you, you
work with somebody or you know,
somebody who's willing to be authentic
with you about their struggles,
you actually feel more connected to
that person when they share that.
How many people have had that experience?
Just raise your hands.
And it's so funny cause I think we're
afraid that's going to drive people away.
But in my research,
what I found is that people who are
willing to embrace that vulnerability,
that's what made them authentic.
And that's what made other people
able to connect with them and with,
with their brands.
And they were actually more able to
make their contribution out of that
vulnerability than less able to make it.
So yeah, it's a great question. Thank you.
What else? Other questions
please. Hi, my name is Brooke.
Thanks for being here. Pleasure. Um,
kind of a tag along question to that.
At what point is an overshare
nausea and at what point?
Certainly taboo subject,
right? For example, like
relationship issues, addiction,
something like what if you want
to share that openly and brightly.
But that is such a great
question. Well, one thing is I'll,
I'll tell you a little story,
which is somebody I was,
when I was writing my last book, the,
the brand mapping strategy books,
somebody called me and
they told me the story.
They told me to go online
and look at this thing up in,
this woman had been on Facebook and she
had been sharing about some guy she had
dated the night before and it
was very explicit and whatever,
I won't tell you any details. It was
cause that would be oversharing. Um,
it was very explicit.
And then somebody else said to her,
why are you putting this publicly
on Facebook? And she goes, oh no,
I thought I was sharing it in the
private area. And they go, no,
you're sharing it publicly. Everyone can
see this. And it became this whole thing.
And she actually got fired from her job
because her clients saw it and it was
pretty risque stuff.
So I think one thing is I see a lot of
sharing on Facebook that when I see it,
I cringe and I go,
that's too much information.
That's oversharing because anybody
can see it, a client can see it,
an employer can see it, so we used
to have this thing we used to say,
which is don't put anything in
public on the Facebook, Twitter,
whatever.
Don't put anything out there in public.
You wouldn't want printed on the
front page of the New York Times.
So when it comes to social media,
that's one of the ways to think about it.
How would I feel if this was on the
front page of the New York Times?
Would I be okay with that? If you
would be, then put it, if you wouldn't,
then don't. I think when it
comes to the personal sharing,
I think you have to make a distinction
and the distinction is the relationship,
the container of the relationship you
have with the person. In other words,
is this person a coworker,
but they're also a friend and
you talk about personal things.
I think when there's that container,
then it's fine.
Especially if you have a confidentiality
agreement to share those things with
each other. I think when the
container is that your coworkers,
but you're not really personal friends,
you have to think about is
that information something
that's going to burden the
person because they're going to feel like
they have to keep it from other people.
So you're now putting a burden on them
or is it something that's going to affect
their relationship with you in a
way that's negative or difficult?
So I think part of it is it's,
it's really a case by case basis,
but we have a big problem in today's
world with oversharing. I mean,
how many of you go on Facebook
sometimes and you literally go,
why did that person put that on
Facebook? You, you wonder that,
how many people view of you
have wondered that? I mean,
I could give you so many more
examples and it's, you know,
now we've got people showing
videos of things and I'm like,
why are they putting that video on
Facebook? Right. Does that help? Yeah,
it's very good. Thank you.
Other questions, please?
Um, so I've been thinking a lot about, um,
juggling kind of an aspirational personal
brand and something that you really
actually haven't done yet. Um, I feel
like a couple of my peers would say, well,
I'm a marathon runner. And you'd say, Oh,
well what marathons have you run in the,
well, you know, I'm training for one or
you know, I'm a community architect. Well,
what communities have you built?
And so it's not dishonest because
there's a genuine desire to get to that.
Um, but it just ends up feeling a
little shallow and without integrity,
even though they do have the skills or
they're working towards getting to that
brand. Right. That makes sense.
So how would you recommend kind of working
towards something and trying to get
yourselves into yourself
into that next step? Um,
while not being kind of dishonest and
kind of seems like it's, it's lying.
Yes.
That's a great question because we have
a lot of things get hyped up today,
right? We hype things up. Like people
say, I'm a writer really? Well,
what have you written? Well, nothing,
but I'm writing, you know, so it's like,
I think part of it is we've lost that
distinction of of what those achievements
are. So I think part of it
is you really just said it.
It's being honest with people.
I don't think you need to say I a member.
The thing about roles,
marathon runners, a role,
you don't have to identify
yourself by that role to say kind.
One of my projects this year is I'm,
I'm training to run a marathon, right?
I'm really,
really into the athletics is sure.
I'm really trying to have a
breakthrough in my athletic ability.
I'm training to run a marathon.
You don't have to give yourself the label.
And I think we are B again.
I think part of it is we get into this
thing this day where we feel like we have
to label everything. I'm a writer,
I'm a marathon runner, I'm an artist,
whatever it is.
And part of it is if we can let go
of the identification with the role,
then we can talk about it from the
point of view of what we're learning.
You know, I'm, I'm studying Spanish, you
know, I'm learning to run a marathon.
You know, I'm, what was the other
example you gave? Yeah, I'm,
I'm studying how to be a community
architect or I'm really passionate about
community architecture.
We don't have to have ourselves
in a fixed position as the role.
Does that make sense?
And part of what happens with,
with social media is we get encouraged
to categorize ourselves a lot.
We get encouraged to categorize ourselves.
I can check the boxes for
all of the different things.
Like that's what our brand is.
And what I'm saying is our brand
isn't really those roles. It's,
it's what we bring to it. It's what
we can tribute. I got for myself.
Like I consider myself a lifelong learner.
I'm always going to be learning something.
When I was in my forties I took up
tap dancing. I wasn't very good at it,
but I would never say I'm a tap dancer.
No one would ever say that.
But I would say to feel I'm, I'm
studying tap dancing. It's really fun.
I'm learning a lot because I didn't have
to be identified in the role. Right.
So it's like it's a matter of what, like
right now I'm learning to make jewelry,
but I would never say my, I would
never call myself a jeweler. I could,
but I wouldn't because it's,
I don't need to be identified with that
role right now. It's just like, oh,
I'm learning something new. I'm
learning to make jewelry. How Fun.
So I think part of it is we want to
get everything kind of like box down to
these are our seven roles and these are
the seven roles are what define who we
are.
And it's the,
and what I'm saying is the opposite is
the roles aren't really what we are,
it's the quality.
So maybe the quality for the person
running the marathon is challenging
themselves.
So the thing to talk about is I love
to challenge myself and my new way,
I'm challenging myself as I'm running,
I'm learning to run marathons.
Does that make sense?
Because then you're focusing on the
quality rather than the role itself.
And that's a really key point because
we do tend to lead with our roles.
We tend to lead with our resumes,
like that's our brand and it's not,
or that that's our contribution
and it's not. Well,
I really want to thank you
for your time and attention.
I know how hard it is to get away from
work and come to something like this.
So thank you for your time.
I hope this was useful for you.
And if you have any questions,
please feel free to reach out to me.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].